il n'y aura conservatrice ça ça ne se
perd pas ça me concerne c'est mon avenir
c'est passé à les limites c'est plus mon
avenir que l'avenir des gens qui ont 50
60 ans l'europe de demain c'est-à-dire
une europe vraiment solidaire une europe
volontaires décidés à aller de l'avant
c'est une europe qui peut apporter qui
apportera aux jeunes d'aujourd'hui une
chance nouvelle une chance nouvelle pour
l'emploi une chance nouvelle pour
découvrir de nouvelles aventures de
nouveaux horizons et j'espère que nous
serons très nombreux au parlement
européen pour défendre les aspirations
des jeunes de france et leur préparer un
meilleur avenir
l'europe elle en parle beaucoup de ce
problème du chômage mais les mesures moi
je les ai pas entendus les politiciens
du 4 il parle
de grands projets mais il parle pas de
tenues de me préoccupe c'est manger
pouvoir vivre ctc avoir un salaire vous
savez je viens d'une région qui est le
nord pas de calais qui est la région la
plus jeune de france et j'habite une
ville où le taux de chômage est à 23% et
un quartier j'habite un quartier ouvrier
où 80 % des jeunes de moins de 25 ans
sont au chômage c'est quelque chose
d'intolérable c'est quelque chose que je
ne peux plus supporter et ma bagarre
pour l'europe sera la bataille de la
jeunesse je veux une europe de gauche
une europe solidaire j'en ai assez d'une
europe libérale et d'une europe de
droite je me compte donne enfin à nos
jeunes toutes les chances de sortir de
l'exclusion et d'avoir enfin un avenir
devant eux
pour l'instant ces routes où l'europe
pas pour moi pour en tout cas pour les
chaînes ce que je vois moi c'est que
pour l'instant c'est rien ce qui s'est
passé en france sur le ces ip par contre
le sehy prp l'impression que c'était une
lutte un peu et ses nerfs parce que
maintenant on ne parle plus trop au
printemps lors des manifestations contre
le cep les jeunes ont exprimé leur droit
à l'avenir en faisant reculer un
gouvernement qui voulait instaurer le
smic jeunes une seule certitude demain
l'europe est le seul espace dans lequel
peut se projeter cet avenir les jeunes
ont une responsabilité celle de ne pas
laisser le soin de déterminer ce que
sera cet avenir celle de ne pas laisser
le soin à ceux qui nous ont refusé cet
avenir au niveau national de nous
l'imposer demain au niveau européen
l'alternative est simple demain pleurer
sur un smic jeunes européens ou alors
voté le 12 juin pour une europe
solidaire